So, I've opened up jsonlint.com
which will tell us whether or
not this JSON is in the right format.
Go ahead and copy this object
in just using the curly braces.
I don't need to copy var education.
Paste it in and click Validate.
And scrolling down we can see that
this is, in face, a valid JSON.
>> What if there were errors?
Like what if we erase this comma,
right here?
>> Well, JSONLint would tell us where
the error is, which is a big help.
Let's see, I'll come over here, I'll
delete this comma, and click Validate.
And we can see that there's an error
on Line 11 because we forgot the comma
that comes before it.
The good news is that text editors like
Sublime Text also highlight errors and
help us figure out where
our syntax went wrong.